hi friends so it's been a couple of
weeks since the last episode I know that
I promised I was going to do one every
single week and I've fallen within the
first month of that however I have a
good excuse I was away in Palmer on a
yacht and then in Dubai with my dad it's
a hard life I know this week I'm sitting
down with Youssef and Johnny from
propane fitness and this is probably my
most anticipated episode to date and I
say mine I mean by myself not by anybody
else we're going to be discussing the
ethical use of Technology and how social
networks social media manipulates our
cognitive biases and uses unseen
persuasion techniques to keep you on
site now all of this might sound a
little tinfoil Hadi but I promise you
it's not it is as far as I'm concerned
probably one of the biggest and most
important issues that we've got going on
at the moment if you think about how
ubiquitous phone use is amongst
everybody on the planet the Cambridge
analytical scandal which recently came
out where it turned out that some users
on Facebook's data had been illegally
acquired to manipulate it caused
absolute uproar and all that was
happening there was people were being
targeted with ads and some of the data
had been stolen your phone is stealing
your time and that's the one resource
that we can't get any of it back
that to me is a much bigger scandal that
needs to be spoken about our phones are
with us more than any partner any friend
any family member any pet
hurry any other item that we own they're
with us every single step of the way in
their possessions that we cherish to a
degree and that we live our lives
through there a window between us and
the world they mediate our experience of
the external world and they manipulate
our experience and our judgment
of other people both celebrity unfriend
it's something that we put an awful lot
of faith into and yet our brains are
being hacked by billion-dollar companies
and behind every press of every button
on your phone there is a team of
software engineers who have manipulated
you into pressing that particular button
in order to keep you on site because
they need your attention because that is
how the money is made on that particular
platform so
hopefully you will come out of this
understanding the tactics that are being
used to keep you on your phone you'll be
more aware of why and how this is
happening and also we will give you some
tips and some strategies that you can
implement to mitigate the amount of time
that you get trapped within your phone
so without further ado here we go
selling a dildo on Facebook Marketplace
yesterday rocking rabbit nothing oh you
said I might have sent a TV yeah good
I don't believe when you say it's not
being used yeah what I mean why I'll see
you selling it like who my doesn't being
used maybe it was a gift and they
thought yeah they have two of them still
I wouldn't trust it could have been
purchased ooh thinking that they wanted
to that they overestimated their sexual
appetite I see so either I'm just doing
their they double tops the Add to Cart
button or they tried it didn't like it
either way I'm not putting it in my
vagina I think it's a way it's not just
the vagina is it or bun yeah you're
right
hey anyway that's what's that's what's
so great button yeah we shouldn't
discriminate I think that's very
judgmental of this to assume the donor
judgment on who people that prefer anal
oh yeah people with here with our
bujjamma need to be nice to docking
could use it to docking docks a second
one for docking can you explain in the
clearest possible way what docking is
when a man interpenetrates
another man with his we were tool at or
urinary tract with it
yeah interpenetrates
so he places his appendage into another
man's appendage
so is that right I mean you think it
wouldn't be possible
so when you say appendage you don't mean
I - it's not not entire package yeah
yeah right lip on lip or not I'm not
sure if it's I thought I thought is it
penis one penises are we saying yeah
penis in penis yeah it's a lip on lip on
lip what slip on their little lip
entrance at the top of the penis
maybe you know you maybe don't have that
use but is that the politically correct
non racialist don't be rich I suppose of
it you if it looks like they're like an
old toothless old man from all of the
optimization got to start again no it's
fine we can just go from now hi
[Music]
so it's a podcast avoided for ages but
we keep on having put it off for
different reasons we did a podcast
called distraction is destruction
excellent podcast excellent podcast
program sales.com
forward slash forward slash distraction
will change the link MIT that was that
the one with the yeah with the arms with
your arm things so basically we all are
trying to reduce our phone time or this
is about a year ago maybe try to reduce
our own time and decide to do a podcast
on how it felt when we use iPhone too
much and tactics that you can do to
reduce that that to me felt like my
first Christmas and over the last six
months all of this stuff that I've
learned
feels like finding out that Santa Claus
isn't real then it's all a lie to keep
you inside and you can't get out
just the odds are stacked against you
I've just entered into this world like a
year ago of phone uses maybe something
that I need to consider a little bit
more deeply than I have done and then
now it's just opened up this entire
world of cognitive bias manipulation and
persuasive techniques and a whole lot of
other stuff so it's interesting because
I used to really care about it and I've
just resigned the father did okay I've
without exaggeration this is probably
one of the top five passionate topics
I've got in my life with my really yeah
just using your phone less I guess
creating a you delivered that in the
game down we once did a podcast where
I've had my microphone set up just as I
want it for ages Yusef came in changed
my game and it ruined the entire [ __ ]
thing it was like a half an hour video
sorry it's fine yourself in the middle
of mocking you fear the infection there
about phone use but it's not about the
passionate about funniest thing it's
just I think that it's something that
everybody it's so ubiquitous the problem
of using your phone too much and the the
argument is the technology's neutral
it's how you use it that determines what
the outcome so to speak and that
couldn't be further from the truth that
behind every click of a button there's a
thousand software engineers who have
designed the particular route that you
have taken through that app or through
that website to get you to click on that
thing
hmm and it's a very small it's idiots
it's not even just them sitting and
designing it a priori in a room on their
own it's like data-driven every time it
every time there's iterations of
thousands of people it optimizes more
and more to make you stay on the page
more at war or click the button or well
under split testing clouds are very
innocent oh yeah yeah so it's it's a
combination of the best computers on the
planet the biggest supercomputers
running all of the data that they can
and some of the cleverest software
designers in the world who was setting
them off on the right path yeah and then
you are into it there's stuff like
disinformation this camera generally
because thing just won't go away at the
moment all of the fake news and stuff
like that and that's like to me
personally the fake news and delivering
advertising that's curated heavily
towards what someone thinks that's like
a drop in the ocean
that's mid-year to manipulate what
someone thinks but time is the one
resource that we can't get any any of it
back right and manipulating someone to
be addicted to using an app or
compulsively checking the phone is like
a [ __ ] war crime and we are nothing
you said about dark patterns yeah really
interrupt did you watch that yeah really
interfered defenseless I think there's a
lot of it on the Amazon website so I
thought it's or an app they'd like to
cancel your account you've got to go
through like and it's a really small
print thing I remember you saying
well Amazon comes across as so innocent
because it looks like it's been designed
in 1999 Geocities like really ya know
simple so you think oh well that's a
tripping iron company like it's just a
website we buy things and but actually
it's a Death Star
I remember watching that video thinking
like you know when you you know you use
something a lot charlie get another
example so Facebook's another example
well like you think the designs like
pretty [ __ ] like play school Basic
Instinct yes yeah like guys put a bit
more effort in than a blue banner and a
F in the middle right they said nothing
about as well don't they do they you
can't use that no one can use that it is
a very recognizable blue Wow but you
look at it and think so Amazon looks so
basic the website you know like
everything's in really small font at the
bottom and then black and white not as
there's no moving advert exactly there's
not much going on then you watch the
video that it walks you through what's
actually going on well put links to
description in this it basically thought
through all on purpose
come on for me all of this got kicked
off by a podcast between Tristan Harris
and Sam Harris stomped respond and he is
the founder of time well spent and the
scent of humane technology humane
techcom I think it is that you can have
a look at some of the more stuff about
that and basically he it used to be the
design ethicist or design philosophy at
Google and he started asking questions
about whether or not people are being
manipulated ethically on the phone so I
think this feels honestly feels like I'm
like opening the floodgates to a world
of [ __ ] but really like I genuinely
don't think that there's a topic which
can be more ubiquitous for people to
need to know about like at the moment it
so for me it's really really important
and hopefully people find a little bit
of value in this so basically I think
it's like common I'd say to commonly
accepted amongst almost everybody even
like my mom or my dad know that they
probably use their phones a little bit
too much and a perfect example of this I
couldn't believe it so I've just been
waited to buy I was at the top of the
Burj Khalifa with my dad who hasn't been
on holiday for 17 years all right so I'm
nearly kilometer up in the air lion's
share of a kilometer 148 floor largest
toll
building in the world la tallest
Observatory platform in the world and we
got there dad hasn't been on holiday
maybe two decades right and we've flown
seven and a half hours and paid however
much money and all the rest of it and I
went to the bathroom and I came back out
to see that he was sat down on the couch
on his phone I was like dad you know on
your phone and he was like I'm just just
answering some work emails you do
remember that this was your retirement
trip dad yo the holiday was for your
retirement you're retiring and you're
answering work emails and it's just that
I mean what perfect example of Bhosle
yeah and the thing is so the argument is
that the red circle I'm an apostle yeah
the thing is does he want to check his
phone when he's a hundred and forty
eighth floor of the Burj Khalifa no he
doesn't want to check his phone however
he has checked his phone does that mean
that that's something he wants to do as
wizardry isn't there someone's made you
do something that you wouldn't know if
someone said do you want to check your
phone check and respond to a female the
answer would always be no I don't want
to check my phone and respond to my work
email but they've managed to still make
you do that you see that that's the car
well I don't know where I lie on that
because I I think I do want to check my
phone so I think that was it's five like
I I was in Budapest Rebecca and the
whole time I've got my phone in my
pocket if anyone had ever said that said
to me do you want Johnny maybe have five
minutes to yourself so I think what
Tristan was getting up was the the
present self versus future self and it's
like you sit when your phone and scroll
the newsfeed for half an hour in the
morning mmm but then if you had to ask
yourself was that time well spent
would you have wanted to spend today
half an hour described Jack and he's got
it
especially when you've got to consider
as we say time is the one resource that
you're not gonna get anything back and
you specifically as a person who likes
to be as efficient as he can with his
day like the time that you spend on your
phone which isn't contributing directly
to the objectives that you've got to
that day who's made you choose is it
leisure time does it count as leisure
time so the question is and the main the
main question of this is does it not a
positive for you because if it nets a
positive for you overall then sweet but
the problem is that it's a zero-sum game
we're all different platforms online are
competing for our attention so if
YouTube ads autoplay which they only
done within the last 18 months or last
two years YouTube's autoplay on to the
next video
that upped their time on site by between
five and 10 percent YouTube ads or
YouTube videos youtube added added oh
okay autoplay advertisers that's a
monkey that's a market isn't mine there
isn't it
so YouTube YouTube why they didn't know
my god I need to I need to go and do it
um YouTube YouTube added in autoplay the
next video that increasing their time on
site by five to ten percent there's only
so many hours in the day so that five or
ten percent has come from some lights
either come from someone's spare time or
it's been taken from Facebook or Twitter
on Google or whatever is and what that
means is that Facebook now needs to do
autoplay videos as you scroll down they
need to up their armory it's like an
arms race it's an arms race to see who
can use the most number of manipulative
cognitive bias affecting techniques to
get you to stay on site and the fact of
the matter is that the economy reflects
the more time that someone spends on a
site the more value that company has
because the revenue is generated through
advertising and advertising is mostly
based on how much exposure people gonna
get how much exposure is directly equal
to how much time on site if you can get
people to stay on site irrelevant of
whether or not they want to you make
more money yeah so
[ __ ] when you I think they think he
mentioned in this and it definitely
catches me every single time and this is
this really hurts my pride because I see
my I like to see myself as somebody who
is it the gay porn able is this the gate
it's I I'd like to pride myself in
somebody who can maintain cognitive
effort on a single task having meditated
for so long and he's tried to train for
this that you're easily the best person
I know about that single thing and
that's meditator okay the best like
single focus like he's gonna do
something companies walk deep was it and
do it yeah and yet I am still
defenseless against like okay I need to
quickly check when that person's
birthday is on face book gone and then
ten minutes they say you've closed the
tab you've done loads of other things
and you're like hang on I didn't even do
the thing I went on there for every time
and again this is this is not the the
one of the main points I want to get
across during this podcast is that if
this is happening to you not only is it
not just you that it's happening to but
it's not your fault and I think that
realizing one of the main steps that I
think needs to happen is that firstly
people need to realize that there is a
problem that if they were to look back
at that day and portion out how much
time they spend on the phone that it is
a regrettable action like and this isn't
me saying that people shouldn't use
Facebook and shouldn't use Twitter and
should use Instagram because he enjoys a
view hood net but that's for sure and
there is a museum obviously there if
there isn't there is a Goldilocks zone
of how much time you should be spending
on there and what you're doing with your
time on there as well but the problem is
that these sites are designed in a way
to manipulate your cognitive biases so
that you do not leave and so that you
don't do the thing that you went on
there to do so that you look at the ad
so do you watch the video so that you do
whatever so I mean there's a couple of
examples that are really really good
variable schedule rewards are the
dopamine release technique that slot
machines work on so you press the button
you wait something's gonna happen it's
either something good or something
that's neutral usually Twitter if you
open up Twitter on your phone now press
the button that way
and then you wait for the notifications
to load you'll see that the app loads
then your newsfeed loads and then you
mentions load with a number sometimes
you got because I don't have Twitter on
my phone so I've never seen this I think
basically basically all that happens is
this does it there's a wait there's a
pause between
loading up yeah they could program it so
that it occurred immediately but they
don't and the reason is the amount of
time it takes for that to load so you've
got a loading screen they're loading
yeah then that'll open then that will go
then that will happen and then you'll
see how many mentions you've got that
come up and the reason for that is is
the exact same amount of time wait that
slot machine takes exactly the same on
Instagram so that so the the you know
the alarm bell blasts you know why you
wait because it's that variable
scheduled reward what you for Facebook
if I do the same thing makes you hold a
breath look Instagram load up Instagram
in your newsfeed will load and there
will be a half a second wait between
that and you know any mentions and your
the Reds little tab coming up so it's
the same tactics that make casinos so
compulsive and gambling so addictive
that because were profitable yeah so we
we are addicted to random rewards more
so than predictable rewards which I find
absolutely insane that you there was a
study where they took a bunch of monkeys
in a room gave them made them do a bunch
of tasks and when they discovered one
button to press it would give them a
banana and they would repeat it and and
when they stopped not from happening
they stopped the they disconnected the
button from the reward
the monkeys kept doing it for a bit and
then they stopped whereas on another
iteration of the study they gave the
monkeys random rewards and the monkey
starts to defend that weird rituals that
they thought were creating the reward
but in fact it was just random and they
thought that if I if I didn't get a
reward then maybe I'm just not doing it
right and they keep I've got a walk this
way around the tree you know this with
the button until
well develop these weird rituals but
then when they stopped giving that
random reward that a monkey's carried on
for like a year afterwards or so or
something really there's a there's one
there's one with rats they gave rats
they press the button and it gave him a
tiny tiny amount of cocaine one of them
was I think I've used this example
before one of them was a fixed number of
times one of them was pressed the button
then he came up once and never again one
of them was random and the random rat
iteration they snapped their spines
pressing them try to yeah trying to get
cocaine and it's because this random
this variable scheduled reward is so
powerful at doping dopamine release so
do you know why candy crush was so
successful wasn't because of the game
wasn't because of anything else it's
because of how it manipulate people's
dopamine levels it's the ability it's
it's the lights it's the sounds it's the
numbers it's it calls so why is it why
is it that our notifications on our
phones are read yeah yeah so so that's
what red fruit just to get a kid to me
there was the Twitter's aren't on the
home screen now aunt uncle I've just
just spent a week with my dad and that
would be two dad-ish even fame because I
would normally say aunt because you're
so well-spoken aunt but immediately
alarmed mother father
so I think we're at grandpa one of the
interesting things that you said there
was about going on your phone and trying
to stick to the task in hand like the
rabbit hole that you tumble down like
before you know tweet from yours
everyone makes the job are they loot ask
everyone everyone makes the joke about
you know like you start watching videos
on YouTube and then three hours later
you're watching cats like climb up a
tree that well is that by online is that
time well-spent
no of course it's known like how how is
this it's literally stealing people's
lives it's taking people's lives [ __ ] no
not that was in earnest
so it's the it's when you put it on our
jury
this is going to just devolve into da
Joe I'm ready for I'm ready for that if
you ever done the thing why mark Munson
first mentioned this where you're on
your laptop you're on Facebook and you
have this moment of like no I'm talking
wasting my time
close the tab open a new tab
[Laughter]
www.littleindiana.com you do a lot of
work I know that YouTube both try and
get yourselves off your phones as much
as possible but the phone is it's so
idiosyncratic and I think that's a big
part of it like I know friends who have
got a cycle that they move through in
the listeners might do as well they know
right okay I go top left first cuz
that's Instagram I'll clear off
everything on there then I'll go on to
Facebook go clear off everything on
there but it between all of these you're
answering and replying anyway so by the
time you've gone through snapchat and
whatsapp and everything out messenger
and all the rest of the things you've
actually got remember ones number one to
pop back up again here and you're like
right kill this in [ __ ] it this is
just an endless loop and it probably
gets worse it's probably just Fanning
the flames of a fire to them
absolutely because it what it's created
what social media is created is a sense
of missing out yeah there is stuff
happening all around you all the time
like but until you open up Instagram and
see that your friends are away on
holiday or see that all of your buddies
have gone out to the pub or whatever it
is you don't have that desperate sense
of I'm not part of it and by logging in
logging checking your newsfeed you
almost begin to start to mitigate that
sense of missing out a little bit so
that's our don't want to know I want it
to be very very serious because I do
think that it is but I don't want people
to feel like they're culpable for it
because the techniques that are being
used that manipulate your cognitive
biases are not it's not things that are
part of your control a good quote from
the Tristan Harris and Sal Harris there
are many things that are bugs not
features about the human mind
and those are the things that are being
manipulated you're not being encouraged
to do things your minds being hacked
that's the reason that you're staying on
site that's the reason that you're not
doing the things that you saw so maybe
the trouble is if you think there's a
way to stop you use don't you probably
then have to start defensively using
your phone with equal force and thought
as the people who are trying to so you
need to recruit the team of a thousand
software and J's and a supercomputer to
split test YouTube meteorites me versus
billion dollar valuation companies in
certain Silicon Valley
yeah so we talk to Lin on we in well in
the last episode of destruction is
destruction we covered a few of the
tactics that we use ourselves to try and
battle it slightly so Chris was talking
about moment V app that you set the
timer limit on your phone and when you
go over it it gives you a really
annoying Bell I just ignore it
I've stopped using time stop using that
sort of I would I would advise everyone
who's listening to download moment it's
free it's on our iOS and Android less
you want the proper one unless you're on
the pro version which we've got all of
us have got because we're pros are not
using on there no cool pro you'll get it
because you'll email them in our script
yeah that's fine until then they'll do
it the other tactics I think were so for
me
what's up is on the sixth page of my ops
under a folder called Cu and T times ten
in capitals so that when you go to it
you just yeah it makes it just so that
you feel the pain of I think a things I
think that we can probably run through
some of the the best the best tactics
that you can use to use your phone less
I do want to try and slight in the most
insidious tactic I think that any of the
any of these social networking sites
have added in which is snapchat snap
snap streaks do you know what this is is
that where you get scores based on how
many times you've send a person it's not
tracking back and forth between someone
but it only it resets if you miss a day
I find
interesting that use you find this the
most insidious one because I because I
know they said that they thought
snapchat was the biggest exploiter of
these tactics first thing it's [ __ ] but
you don't understand if you don't
understand it it's like 75% of
communication online between people
under the age of 15 is very chatty yeah
absolutely young it's out of this snaps
treats it snaps treat thing so I heard
this story right people go what these
kids will go away on holiday with their
parents and they'll give their logins to
a friend who's back in the UK so that
they can continue to message their
friends backwards and forth their other
friends just to keep the snap streets
going use and like there's people with
that thousand thousand days snap streaks
of having to message so that's forcing
someone to go back and forth and I
remember one of my main one of my mates
up now even with his missus because he
broke her the the snap streak between
them is there anything more in name than
that so like having out of all the
things he could have an argument over
like because if you're forcing someone
to have contact that they wouldn't
necessarily have oh you do you know what
you did today Yousef you ruined our
forced communication number that judged
how many times we had to send a message
to each other when we didn't want to so
yeah it cheapens it in the first place
but when you break the streak and you
just get your head above the water for a
second it's like like when when I broke
my MyFitnessPal German when I did I was
like you know what like nothing's burnt
down fine
see I felt like everything I've been
done really I was knocking on the door a
thousand two did a part of the
competition the Hearst welfare Center in
Washington is a total dead spot for all
communication tracked everything on
David powerlifting you've got home
realize that I hadn't sink before
there's no night Wow lost what a killer
never get back what you said about when
you spend five hundred pounds you'll
never you'll always be firing phones
with us where software to do that I mean
that's the most use of analogy any of
this isn't it so if you never spend
any money you will always have always
better off yeah always better off he was
so shaken by his like Batman who depends
always be nice that's how I feel this
past week thing would I be on now I was
annoyed look whatever is whatever is now
plus 1000 it's because you drive with
you drive with a functional car into an
MOT Center it's fine but you drove them
and then you drive you away to tell you
need $10 island Japan's worse off but
there's no difference to you you still
driving a car that's so it was a danger
to other motorists you use a 900-pound
danger to other motorists supposedly
that's like saying you don't need to
brake but you know I should have gone
you should have gone Bitola Warren G you
should have gone to our guy
I should we've got a guy this is a prize
me oh great now if we have a guy who
makes it now and he kicks the tires a
bit you guys I saw must buy [ __ ] guy
we have a saying in Egypt that breaks a
pansies so do you know the the driving
test is drive 10 meters forward dropped
his ears backwards easiest place on the
world to to pass the driving test yeah
if you project it to college it is
people reversing up a slip road is a
common that's why you've got - come yeah
isn't it it's you I've got I just I
thought it was so you could capture all
of your dogging experiences on the front
of you from Cairo has just been
imprinted onto me I'm talking of course
but um you know how many hours a video
is watched on YouTube every month I'd
love to know but I don't know guess what
okay
alright come on Scott between us we can
put together a really dress hundreds of
them at least at least an hour I reckon
that's just you isn't it between us we
would watch an hour
Tom Marlon just a Tom Mark just probably
the same video yeah so what's the you
know time a day no no a month in a month
let's figure out in a day so I'll see
I'll just I'll just no no god damn us
together
don't ask you to do something huh you
don't actually want to listen to doom
okay okay right 500 million users daily
or more probably more No okay so well
it's probably a billion users fine it 1
billion users daily each one 10 minutes
10 minutes okay so is that be some
people be some people who use it party
rule and some prizes so 150 million
hours per day times 30 fast maths isn't
it no highs election Egyptian doctor
let's say four point five trillion hours
sorry no it's not four point five
billion hours 1 billion won the recently
celebrated 1 billion hours oh well
that's really disappointing well yeah I
mean you got your maths wrong but yeah
they said they recently celebrated a
billion hours a month which is like
metal is that the the celebrating
wasting a billion hours of human there
could be a straightening the argument is
and his is the busier as we see the
ratios this is the sort of the main
thing pornhub stats let's get on to that
we'll get caught up so that's up shortly
the the main thing is that inherently
using your phone isn't a bad thing it's
only a bad thing if in retrospect you
wouldn't have wanted to use it this is
the same analogy and the best analogy
that I can come up with is how do you
know that right ok so the best analogy
that I can come up with is eating sweets
because what you want what you want is
not necessarily what's always good for
you right I want to eat the sweet in
retrospect I might glad that he ate the
sweets no I'm in a [ __ ] deficit at
the moment why would I have eaten no
sweet in fact I would argue that from
the moment I say from half an hour after
you eaten in the sweets
forever in the future you wished that
you hadn't eaten half an hour after
spending immediately after spending nine
hundred pounds as MOT so you H you
probably didn't want to spend nine
hundred pounds in a baby never did know
so never a topping it to which
so like if someone said would you have
wanted to eat those sweets from last
year or a month ago or three hours ago
you'd always say I wish I hadn't but
then let's say there are seafood macros
if they think you must be with you again
that's it that's the there's a
Goldilocks zone for how much you can use
your phone I got it and here's one as a
bit on the phone macros yeah pretty much
here's one of the big things and it's
the outrage online always travels
further than positivity and because of
the way that the newsfeed optimization
works this is specific to Facebook
outrage is more attractive than
positivity that means that you are more
likely to click on outrage all that the
computer is then going to start feeding
you is more of what you want or are hang
on but what about the sweet analogy I
ate the sweet but I kind of didn't want
to eat the sweets but I did kind of want
to eat this week I don't want to click
on the outrage I don't be delivered more
outrage but all that the computer is
doing is delivering more of what its job
is which is to maximize time on site and
to maximize click-throughs plus when you
have a squeeze I think it creates the
immediate desire from what another suite
sees about the suite you don't think
that was lovely
enough enough you think that was nice I
don't know in fact that's a really good
analogy because we know that you're the
bacteria that develop in your gut as a
result of certain foods will cause
they'll interact with your brain and
cause you to crave more of the same food
and so that's a double-edged sword as
with outrage that if you consume lots of
our rage that's going to then change
your mental environment over time and
change the general tone and emotion that
you're experiencing throughout the day
well one of the way people do for
gratitude journals because they want to
fill themselves with positivity one of
the main things is that because because
of how Facebook works and because it
delivers news to people who they know
want to see it there was a time online
where if the word Trump was in an
article it would be top of your newsfeed
irrelevant of what you'd clicked on
there was a brief period where that
happened was it's a truck just Trump
literally Trump to the top everything to
the time the changing it trumped
Top Trumps and yet a face but the thing
with Facebook is that because it will
get you to click on things that you have
a particular cognitive bias towards and
it segregates you into these echo
chambers online with other like-minded
people that share the [ __ ] that you want
to click on but that you potentially
don't want to click on then you don't
even know you're in it know and the
outrage not good for you it's not it's
not good for you all so unless you're
right in which case it's fine then you
just confirm confirm right um I think
that talking about some solutions for
this is probably a big deal the first
the first part of it the first thing
that I wanted to try and achieve was to
let everyone know that it is a little
bit of a problem it's a massive problem
and that you do need to be conscious of
how much you use your phone and I don't
want it to be I would actually argue now
that it is come for me a real vise when
I'm self referential about when I use my
phone I like regret I regret being so
silly as to have used it which
previously up until learning that you
were potentially being manipulated and
then it is not time well-spent that's
something that you might not have done
but the end goal is more worthwhile it's
the same thing is knowing like up until
the point in which you knew that smoking
might cause cancer you were fine smoking
a cigarette
now the know that it might do you feel
guilty about smoking a cigarette this is
something I used to enjoy now it's
something that I feel is I've heard a
similar thing about porn which is that
your face letter pursuits there was a
counter you know how I like so the
amount of porn on the Internet's
increased rapidly over time there's a
point in time where no one watched any
porn now pawns I mean you'll tell us it
starts in a second he'll give you some
stuff there's a lot of porn
yeah and then there's an argument to say
actually worrying about how much porn
you watch is what can be more damaging
than just watching a visit um
that's what I was gonna say was the
chris said that you have to that
you use a phone if you get a net benefit
from mmm using it and what you've done
by creating a cycle of guilt with using
your phone is that you've reduced the
net benefit that you get from using your
phone or potentially remove the chance
of getting a net benefit completely
which could kill all that you see could
have pulled it on dry so maybe you've
actually tricked yourself into using
your phone less in a very convoluted way
mm-hmm which is good you know what I
would love to see and I don't know
whether this is that's on porn hook I've
got some mints that's I would love to
see them but separately so the Cambridge
analytical stuff like before I left the
house there was a new story about
something about Facebook leaking data to
the party apps and things like that I
would love to know whether Facebook
Timeline screen is decreased since all
this came out and I would imagine I'd
love to know I imagine it hasn't I bet
it took a very marginal denman then it's
gone but look at what did look at what's
the number one new source for most
people is it Facebook betwe it's
actually Twitter people are finding
actually about Facebook news news leaks
on Friday no leaks on Facebook and
surely Facebook can just remove there's
anything there was news feeds no
mentions but remember when that remember
giggle got pulled for putting their own
shopping yeah things at the top of
particular list there's like this fair
use policy thing isn't it like where
well this is my platform I can do
anything I want well no actually you're
supposed to be neutral in a way but okay
you're neutral it did at the content
that you deliver but not neutrally
delivering the content and just a tough
one that isn't it it is really the wrong
way like they're not a charity though
you know they're a business profit
driven life course again appetizer and
services on their own platform I think I
think the other thing to consider is as
well that everyone believes that if you
would do if you to look at this from a
very critical perspective you would
think that all of the guys in Silicon
Valley were in black hoods and long
noses sat around a wooden table chanting
and like doing like the just it's a
nefarious company that
you see trying to steal your time but
they're not that just trying to maximize
profit profit is the attention economy
means that profit is directly on
revenues directly related to time on
site that means that maximizing time on
site is all that matters and if outrage
and cognitive bias manipulation and snap
streaks and autoplay videos that's kind
of worse in a way that there's no
conscious or moral consideration at all
will it be worse than if they were
saying we actually want to go out of our
way to destroy people's lives I mean
that would be worse but I think it sound
very linear what's happening because if
you can visit that's your intention
they're achieving it if you can change
them you could if you could twist on
Harris's argument is if you could change
the economy to reward businesses somehow
based on how much value they add to
someone's life rather than their time on
site but they would change in a
heartbeat but is that not what sucks up
is trying to do because you know time
well-spent is a snippet from his thirty
his big post that he did it's the other
way around
oh is it yeah so it says oaks are copied
Tristan isn't really okay so is that not
why he's saying like all of the fake
news is gonna be removed and like we're
gonna penalize like business pages and
that's fine but again all of that is
what we're talking about there is the
content that's being delivered not how
not you deliver things every message not
really and you know because he's not
going to say oh we're actually want to
encourage you to spend less time on
Facebook what he wants you to do is the
time on Facebook that you spend to be
more meaningful which is fine but there
is always like no one's attacking
BuzzFeed well I've never once read a
BuzzFeed article that afterwards I
haven't regretted and that isn't yeah is
a factual statements because they're
misbranded it's just clickbait Shae
isn't it should we have a look at some
stats on porno
so the I I won't take I take my hat off
to the young analyst the analyst who
nice starts they are right imaginative
it's a data team
probably this song so I bloke with a
spreadsheet Rudi Hellmich you know how
much yeah twenty-eight point five
billion annual visits to pornhub this is
the most interesting stat right 28.5 84
per year per person for what four visits
per year purpose that's presuming to all
seven accessing porn including newborns
people on their deathbed yeah people in
third world countries once every three
months let's really get running water
someone have attention to some
aboriginals somewhere they [ __ ] got
porn yeah so twenty-eight point five
billion annual visits to pornhub but
only twenty five billion searches
performed now what that means is that I
mean said nailed on 3.5 billion people
have clicked on something that's
appeared on their suggested videos at
the start now I don't mean I don't meant
I don't mean to sound like an aficionado
but I've got higher standards for my
pawn them just clicking on the first
thing that comes through I mean nominate
you've chosen you've chosen to watch
something that's taken no investment fee
from you to watch it just the very least
thing you could do is [ __ ] refine it
yeah I think someone's just gone on and
on but there we go so I would like to
play devil's advocate and so that we
don't know that there was 3.5 billion
that were hits but didn't search
necessarily clicked on the video they
may have gone on it oh no not today I'm
not gonna pawn today really dividers
going with themselves about their no
[ __ ] this probably is it'll be at the be
chunk of people in there he'd go on
there and do leave so I wonder what the
split is people who just click on them
the first failure they see I think the
number of people who typed pornhub in
visit pornhub and then decide not to use
pornhub probably in the minority really
it's it's not because with Facebook I
often will open Facebook and then know
I think this be the emotional
psychological hormonal drivers behind
looking at porn her versus looking at
Facebook be quite different now I don't
I don't know what you do on Facebook or
what you do on porno pull up mother did
you believe this this is the this is the
best step over the course of 2017 there
were a hundred and twenty million video
votes on pornhub which is a million
votes more than was cast in the last US
presidential election is mental
so what you get foot Cambridge
analytical yeah so when hardness is
spline is low for the whole but we need
to know how many unique because that
could be one guy but in everybody
million times do that blows got a lot of
times you go ahead that's a guy really
focusing on time well spend isn't there
you know what I want to know that I have
a burning desire to know this is how
many people pay for porn hood preemie
yeah they're definitely not gonna reveal
that are they because it would be
terrifyingly low because the answer I
bet you it isn't the variety of content
that you get already on pornhub just
what sir so they're operating the
freemium model
so they over deliver on the front end
and and what that makes everybody think
is a holy [ __ ] what must have paid model
look like Jab Jab right hook
exactly yeah Gary it's just Gary
Vaynerchuk behind those I revena chose
any Mohammed nurse only thought so
because seeing their financials would be
do you know what they did Joe Rogan did
an interview with the guy who was
involved in a start-up of pornhub and
they just bought up everything they
bought it so it's an xx
like they bought every video streaming
service as it came up boy didn't used
like we're still running approval no no
no I'm still it's still run is like a
separate site however but they own it
they don't like and staff how much they
are and I want to say like someone might
call me out on this I want to say it's
like more than 80% of like porn
streaming worldwide they command is
under desk
where they just buy out all the
different soap companies and give the
illusion of choice you go to the border
I mean if if there was if there was some
if there was some real like market fare
like a governing body here regulators
absolutely being a monopoly claim going
in for the fact of the matter is its
porn so I was like no wait like no I'm
not right again no come back
all stop it yeah so right let's do some
reductions of phone use strategies mine
have developed since last year since I
last did that name one
my main one is that when you are an in
in an inertial frame of reference the
likelihood of you staying on your phone
is higher so if you're lying down it's
more likely than if you're sitting and
if you're sitting it's more likely than
if you're standing and if you're
standing it's more likely than if you're
walking so the fact is jumping jumping
yeah yep flying flying and flapping it's
the huffing [ __ ] yeah
snatching do not try and snatch with
chin-ups unless you dmitriy klokov
but it's impossible isn't it jeez your
phone why you doing this you know it
depends how strong you are 100 shut up
fun and basically what did lift didly
didly impossible um basically don't use
your phone don't use your phone when
you're an inertial frame of reference
so if you are just trapped is between
his chin and is between his beard is our
beard it worked it's fun this panis it
just you said you faster doctor in his
trance wheezes speaking of which Robby
trapped his glans penis doing lateral
raises glans omegle in Agra what's a
bruised clitoris clitoral integrant yeah
well if you are an Olympic weightlifter
potentially one who's coming back from
the Commonwealth Games which is recently
in Australia and you are suffering with
clitoral mega Negron
we are telling one fact we had someone
opt into our e-mail list called Zoe
Smith right who there's a weightlifter
he was just came back from Commonwealth
Games called Zoe Smith you have made a
cake with her once so he doesn't
presumed emailed her and when is this
the same Zoe Smith that I made a cake
with she emailed us look I didn't he
doesn't I'm not doing anything I'm just
is this the same Zoe Smith no reply
thank you bye to you reply to me saying
sadly not oh good it that's a shame so
time time time return a phone so quick
best best thing but best few things to
do do not sleep with your phone by your
bed so put your phone over there by
phone
put your phone of the far side of the
room put the charger over the far side
of the room it's the first step that
means that if you want the phone to be
charged the next day you've gotta go
over there stacking the deck in your
favor against having it near your bed it
means that when you wake up on a morning
like I can't believe I cannot believe
that these like doormat alarm clocks
that you have to stand on for 10 seconds
a school have been it why I mean that's
you see wall over isn't just put your
font put the alarm on your phone no you
meant trying cancel my account like I
can't do it and yeah put your phone over
the far side of the room I do the next
to the window so it means that when you
wake up in the morning you do that my
advice would be do not look at your
phone for anything other than turning
off your alarm clock unless you have
desperately need to do it ie waiting
someone to come and pick you up
police police do not do not pick your
phone up until after you've done
everything that you need to do in the
morning that includes making breakfast
having coffee setting yourself up for
the day ideally until he get in the car
if you're doing meditation if you're
doing ROM WOD if you're doing anything
else look at the phone like when you
open up the phone direct yourself
immediately to the app that you need to
use second one from me is to remove all
social media websites from the homepage
of your phone I think that for many
people
almost everybody uses their phone in
some way or another that's related to
work or contacting friends and I think
that an outright deletion of social
media off your phone can be a little bit
extremely some people although that's
the goal take it off your homescreen and
move it into a folder somewhere that you
need to swipe through for quite a while
to get to also remove the number
notifications from everything except for
things that are generated by other
humans so for me I've kept mine on for
messenger for Facebook I've kept mine on
for whatsapp but not for group chats the
reason is that if someone is messaged me
specifically
that's probably actually worthy of my
time I know that it sucks you into using
the phone but that for me it's probably
not far off time so that's not you would
become a Facebookers human-generated
for the most part because there isn't on
there is a unfair weight towards
computer generated the right or those
messages basically but emails message
you direct down how do you eliminate
group chat notifications on once a
wampum notifications group
chungcheong-do really yeah and you can
leave like normal ones on I really do
that and then turn off also right and
with drip drip chats the problem with
group surveys of a life
yeah they just they can rack up like
really really quick and you think if you
have them on notification it's a meme oh
yeah there's clear on your homescreen
you look at your home screen kills you
condoms um next one Johnny if you go
I've already I've already ignored you
it's still bothering you
Johnny what do you got have you got any
tactics that you use for phone reduction
so the one I mean you both experienced
when I went through my phase with my
[ __ ] phone I think for me that is the
one that I would aspire to be briefly
explain so I bought a 20 pound phone on
Amazon which is the most basic phone you
can imagine it has a torch what does he
call it again she shivered
oh yeah the Boston
so ADH a are sta so which is a reference
to a YouTube video because we will spend
too much time on you I've achieved that
we can actually reference the I if
anyone would like access to the funniest
collection of YouTube videos there's no
exaggeration Yusuf's
how many at seven hundred probably like
it is curated content like it is really
high-quality that's the time well spent
that is time excellently spent
excellently well time so yeah um and for
a 24-hour period once a week
take your SIM card out of your iPhone or
your Android and put it into the chef
phone and then you wake up the next day
and it is weird what were the barriers
that you found so that's so you said the
heart the hardest thing is or was they
like I would go with my girlfriend
somewhere so like she'd be shopping or
would be like we go to Tesco and you
find yourself in these periods of dead
time where you you go to check it anyway
so I find myself getting about my pocket
looking at it and then thinking I mean
that's the that's the what am I gonna
really see what I'm gonna do I turn the
torch off that's so interesting it's
it's compulsive phantom compulsion and
yeah it's such a it's that's the
idiosyncrasy side of it there's this
really good meme thats are online it's
about a guy sitting on the subway this
person's speaking in the third person
they're saying I saw this guy's saying
across from me it's a cross for me on
rush hour on the on the train as
everyone else was sat looking at their
phones and he was just sat there staring
out of the window like a psychic like
say you're having a coffee just we're
not texting yeah you know I mean like
yeah the the compulsion to check and
this is the thing because the
introspection occurs such a new thing as
well ten years ago that would be normal
yeah yeah introspection occurs during
periods of boredom like periods of
boredom allow you to ask yourself
questions throughout the
sit and think yeah yeah like when do you
have like if you were told to go and sit
in a room now for 30 minutes you
couldn't meditate hmm so you couldn't
actually do what we would do when we had
a little bit of silence you taught to go
and sit in a room for 30 minutes
the number of people that would give up
it's not considered the greatest
punishment to put someone in solitary in
solitary confinement is no stimulus the
other thing the worst highest level
people would prefer to be in with prison
with rapists than by themselves then on
the wrong yeah and there's been my first
thought with for that is I would just
thousands of hours of meditation
Navis well yeah that's fine I want to be
the man I got come out of prison
anywhere else at a terrible time just
glowing blue light okay so you had you
yes there is there is the ultimate fear
of you go to you take the SIM card out
of your phone and there's this fear sets
in of like what is going to happen over
the next 24 hours I message what about
yeah so I think I want with that for me
is business-related but I know that
there's a scone yeah so you did
sometimes call me but the thing about
that is that when you called me on my
[ __ ] phone days there is this utter fear
that sets in because you're like I know
that he will have hesitated before
ringing me this is still a serious yeah
and so you see some vehicles let's
change your ringtone I'm gonna break I'm
gonna break the fourth wall of podcast
recording and say that I next week there
is going to be a conversation with
caiway who is CEO of the light phone
calm however I've already had the
discussion with him but that's that's
really interesting and you'll find out
what is potentially a more palatable
solution to Johnny's [ __ ] phone probably
the shite phone the [ __ ] phone problem
there are so many different problems
the mainly it takes a lot of discipline
to say I'm gonna [ __ ] phone day tomorrow
and there's always a reason I will [ __ ]
fun day hmm
Yussef some strategies very similar to
yourselves I think that the general
principle with everything we've said so
far is make the good decision as easy as
possible and make the bad decision as
hard as possible so we have the
low-hanging fruit right exactly yeah so
we have the the apps on the final page
and call it something like your dick
there's gray scaling your phone which I
tried for a while but I've tried that
too doesn't it it just annoyed me I
don't think it made me use it less it
just meant that when I took photos I had
to double check that background black I
think that there's a bit ok which makes
it slightly less visually stimulating
the grayscale is irritating mm-hmm I
think that that probably sacrifices some
of the experience of what you are going
to use it for
while it's not really not making much of
a difference to the things that you
wanted to change yeah yeah exactly
the only other things for me is I always
have it on silent unless everything I do
not disturb mode except for a select few
people that when they call me if I am I
wonder if those people of course owe you
money yeah Johnny isn't it's gonna be
you the one who includes me to turn off
all notifications that has been they
because the massive the credits such a
such a big change and the thing is like
you can you can keep a select few
I've got personal messages on whatsapp
I've got a message Facebook's gone
Twitter's gone or Facebook pages if
you've run Facebook pages you'll know
what we mean from the app that's gone I
bet you've got I do got ads manager
notifications on be about just strike
just wanna make money yeah so the only
note there anytime my firm makes a noise
is either when you surf changes the time
that he's going to purchase kabuki
moving system or
calendar calendar reminders or when we
make yourself I think calendar reminders
although I don't have notifications for
that I make an exception for it I think
because it's important you may
that notification to report is someone
else putting something in my schedule
for me which is also important I mean
isn't it isn't it isn't it crazy that we
were sat discussing ways to stop the
things that we voluntarily bought from
this new home is dug around together in
mine this thousand pound a year
investment that is with us 24 hours a
day the most ubiquitous piece of
technology that Spa forever existed and
we're having to come up with strategies
to try and fight back against
billion-dollar companies but it's it's
really powerful which makes it fantastic
in many ways like the things you can do
with it a brilliant unbelievable look
that it everything has a side effect
isn't how much and how much how much of
what we're talking about it's time well
spent like because for me like the
Tristan came up with some good some good
erm the stats on it and he says that
number one two and three Facebook
Instagram and snatcher the three most
regretted uses of apps and I think that
one two and three of the on the ops end
of the scale was My Fitness Pal actually
weirdly enough as one of the ones
there's not regretted yeah yeah as Heidi
podcast and mindfulness up yeah you
never like say I wish I don't wasted so
much time on my fitness car today like
it's yeah it's been productive like you
don't you don't go in and scroll through
and like spend too much time looking at
like whether it when it does Charles his
micro even though they try to but the
other thing for me is I've never had
Facebook on my phone and Facebook for me
out of those apps is the most used to be
the most compulsive but now on the Mac
as well I've got a mod that stops the
newsfeed from showing up and so now it's
just Chrome news feed blocker I think
it's cause it may be yeah so I only use
it for I got that as well
purity so we have a Facebook here is e
so really good Facebook for me is only
used for work or marketplace selling tea
salad for two pounds so what what that's
like and I don't know whether you were
about to say this but it's when you go
on to use Facebook and the news feeds
blocks it's like you have to use the
menu items to navigate what you want to
do you don't just get dragged into like
the first
views because I'm such a sucker for that
and I know that I am and there's no
point in me saying oh you know what I'll
just exert more willpower and just then
not get sucked into the yeah I mean one
of the the most crazy ones in it this
will happen to absolutely everybody I'm
going to touch on to two things here one
of the most crazy ones you've had a long
day at work
you've been out you've been proven at
the gym you haven't been in the house
for like 12 hours something like that
you get back you park the car up on the
drive you take your phone out and then
you sit in the car yeah for 20 minutes
yeah there is no more shameful use of
your phone than sitting in the car
outside your house outside your own
house wait I'm done for as well it
happens all the time so it's when your
it's when your your willpower and
discipline is at its absolute lowest and
you're like I'm tired I just can't be
bothered like ah that's a nice where I'd
show anything to look so the same as
like when you're too tired to go to bed
mmm it's just yeah I suppose so or that
you know that you've got to but even
with this it's like you could do the
phone thing while you move mmm do you
know I mean like you could stand up wait
to the inertial frame of reference again
right you comfortable yeah it's Sat you
sat in the car you've been there for a
while you've probably been thinking
about using your phone and here's
another thing like and I don't know why
this isn't a bigger deal
like how many Instagram stories you see
people and we've all been like well
maybe not all of us I don't make you
culpable as well but a lot of us have
been culprits of doing this how many
Instagram stories you see people while
they're [ __ ] driving like the driving
down the street juninho scope no I'd
like this the vast majority of Instagram
users the drive will be able to attest
to it me like that's a really fiddly
thing to do how I'm [ __ ] dead like I
mean I you know I don't refer to put
myself in the firing line but how would
the police not going me hmm that's a
video of you doing something illegal in
your car yeah apparently police are now
riding buses to look they look down yeah
I would love to see people have a
special lorries that they take on
motorways to look down on people
Wow look across at lorry look down up
should just just usually go like look
how small and [ __ ] your car is can
just looking down on you yeah yeah it
was that clip of like ah he said you
removed the guy on his phone
you killed they were sent like what was
it like 20 messages in the space of like
10 miles or something and then that
drove straight in the back of it car
killed the entire family and I don't
know like it's but it is the thing right
that the that they're like do people
want to be on their phone like is your
is using your phone while you're in the
car time well-spent for you or is it
just a you newsfeed scrolling and we we
all we all a someone who I know has a
problem with doing it it's a difficult
problem that many people face and one of
those things that it's fine until it's
not and then you're like that was not
worth the text message that I said or
the course which mean yeah closes heart
and it's what it's the muck so for me I
think the thing you said about not not
looking at it when so something that dan
gibson
dap dop the digital or the broadcaster
hips together has just mentioned to me
which is really interests me because he
he always strikes me as he's a busy guy
from the moment he wakes up to the 7
o'clock at night he's like he's up
rushing i put fire rain it rains it's
like pinching every second out of his
morning then he's at work
finishes that he's like I often ask I'll
allow myself 30 minutes in the evening
to check social media he seems to be
seemed really on top of it and the other
day told me that he's experimenting with
not allow himself to look at social
media in the morning okay so it's
eroding away at you as well like it's
obviously what used to be very
controlled in the opening 30 minutes is
now creeping in the morning yeah now
he's like it's got another point where I
feel like I need to put a boundary on
this I think the easiest way to do it
for me and this is the this harks but
I'm sure that if there's anyone who
understands have its setting better than
I do or we do that they this will be a
common tactic but I made the rule about
when I was going out for drinks if I was
on a student of sobriety then he was my
birthday and I knew that way to have
some drinks but not too many
I had to set myself a hard-line rule mmm
and it's the same with the phone when
you're trying to stop yourself from
doing something your mind wants to do
but in retrospect you don't mm-hmm the
was it the current cell first is the
remembered self yeah you need to set
very very hard lines and one of the
easiest ones to do is to say right up
until a particular point I'm not going
to look at my phone in the morning after
a particular point I'm not going to look
at my phone on a night yeah well the
most productive time I've ever had in my
life and I don't know why that is when I
was I was no Wi-Fi until 3 p.m.
how did you do did you know ultimate
that you that you just went over and
flicked a switch
yeah so just go to bed turn everything
up turn Wi-Fi and connection off on
everything and the next day wake up
purely offline work until 3:00 p.m. is
and then if there was knowledge worker
you asked to communicate with other
people that's probably going to be
difficult then I would mind really turn
on for that one task and turn it back
off again oh my god that is serious and
I had a 30-minute allocation for social
media whatsapp messages at 6 p.m. and it
was beautiful
I mean that is that is the youngest of
the extreme and then I slipped out of
the habit and normal life the best thing
is I what I found I said to Don what are
you doing digital audio did you thought
it order I just acacia just for anyone
who's confused yeah how what are you
doing to ensure that you don't check
your phone before midday because for me
saying like I'll just not do that so you
know people static oh like tomorrow I'm
gonna go on a diet so I get something
that requires willpower that's something
that it's probably currently your norm
and to just click your fingers and
change yeah especially in the morning
you wake up burns by a bit you reach
over turn off your life it's on the
other side of the table of course and
there's loads of red things to check
Alex exciting check that before you know
it you're in theater and it's down down
the line you've been you've got a
physical alarm clock didn't you mm-hmm
just just to avoid lemonade that is such
a good idea I think you need yeah but
the water is what we're talking about
here is hearken back to a you said you
surf which is making the choice you want
to make either in retrospect or in
advance as easy as possible and the
choice that you don't want to make
difficult as possible so yeah you're
right that on a morning it's difficult
not to check your phone where it's a
piece of piss if it's not in your hand
yeah you cannot check your phone if it's
not that so put it put it somewhere you
know I started doing that was to break
the idiosyncratic habit at the start
this year I put my phone in my other
pocket mmm the number of times that I've
taken my wallet out recent huh and
obviously I will I will in 10 minutes
pressing the pressing your wallet new
yet I don't know have a consistent
pocket I do I have it always goes right
on yet so but yeah I think you you just
need to try and do things that are going
to stack the deck in your favor and for
the most part that involves just put
your phone away
so I think that starts with trying to
spot your own patterns doesn't it right
now like when when is it that you look
at your phone like when are you when do
you get really chewed up with time yeah
yeah and again you know he sat down with
a doctor and an accountant The Fairly
figures based you cannot derive much
from the research without having figures
yeah and you need to have some figures
so reality time and moment yeah
rescue time is rescue time his moments
of Macbook right yeah and it's so
depressing look at that send you an
email or Sunday sends me an email every
time time and you know what you know
what my unsubscribed from any my yes so
I did my it's my all tasks the most
valuable part of it I just checked it on
the website he goes and does it by
choice you know my total phone time
since we started using moment which was
after distraction is disruption eighty
about 18 months ago my my total thumb
time is just under $4,000 in 18 months I
spent what over a third of my waking
life on my phone and this is someone
who's trying to do everything in his
power it'll take it will take you I'm
not gonna get the full stats I'm just
gonna get the dailies yeah because you
can see it gives you a percent as you
just listed it gives you a percentage of
waking time on you know feared sounds
about right
the tip that I was going to say that you
told me about was put your apps into a
few folders or off the homescreen and
then use the search function yeah get to
it which is it feels the same to me is
the the newsfeed blocker because you're
on Facebook and you're like what am i
doing what am I here to do yeah you have
to be mindful to choose it no but that's
a that's an option if you go into Siri
on your own you've thought oh if you use
an Android then I have no idea but if
you go into settings and then Siri and
turn off Siri up suggestions then take
all of your apps off the homescreen and
put them into folders to get to the apps
the most convenient way or the quickest
way to do it is to swipe down from the
top and type into a search bar what it
is that you want but to do that you need
to make a conscious choice to type the
letter of the app that you want and to
begin the process which just gives you a
little bit I thought automatic is your
moment just a little bit of a moment
you're just the same thing why am I here
what am i doing what am i doing yeah
it's less of a compulsion because I
found that having the same way that a
river cuts through a bend to find the
quickest way I managed to find a
shortcut to my own ship folder routine
yeah our meeting that within three days
I had found a quicker way that was
quicker than when it used to be on my
home screen that's my home screen yeah I
have to go one two to find my follow
that folder called time wasting that's
where I spend most of my time sometimes
then you just realized that you are such
a fickle bastard who will just overcome
everything you put in your own way why
share fun it's not your it's not your
choice or very much check out the
distraction is destruction podcast I'll
make sure that that is in the links
links to the was it the choice
architecture what was one that you sent
us are you too dark dark patents patents
on YouTube links to Tristan Harris with
Sam Harris and a couple of other
websites that you may be interested in
if you want to find out anymore or if
you've got any questions feel free
tweak'd me or the guys online and we
will catch you next time we got more
lifehacks coming up we've got Kai way
coming up daniel head from rome ward and
quinn henyk of juggernaut training
systems thank you bye bye
[Music]